So back to Anderson though.
Yeah,
so my book ends with him are that first
leave and fight and then shattering his
leg, which I was in the front row
for which you didn't even believe it.
If it didn't make sense to see a leg
move like that, you're like, I don't,
I don't get it. It looked like
somebody filled up a sock with,
with pebbles and just like look at
something and it's like it doesn't,
it didn't make sense and it was so gross.
But in the interim,
seeing that first Chelsea
on and fight when he was,
I mean he won 400 half rounds checks
on it. He almost won the title.
And then to kit that, I mean it
was such a legendary sports thing,
not UFC,
but sports thing.
How this guy's down like
crazy in a title fight.
A guy who's never been tested was
finally tested and was losing.
It was over. This guy could, Chael Sonnen
was beating him. He figured him out.
And then to get that triangle with what,
40 seconds left, two minutes left over.
It was,
but I remember what's so
clear and indelible in my
head is afterwards we're at
the entrance, everyone's cleared out of
the stadium. We're at the entrance to the,
um, to the, under the, you know, the caves
of the, of the stadium, wherever it was.
And it's me, you, I think Dana, uh,
Randy was there and we're all talking.
And then every once in a while somebody's
mind would go to that fight and you'd
just see him go like, yeah, yeah, I
think the weather's pretty nice here.
And then you see someone go like,
like,
you couldn't believe it. I remember seeing
Randy couture, dude. Like, I'm like,
why do this?
Four minutes into the fight grabs a
hold of it or four rounds in the fight,
grabs a hold of it,
syncs up the triangle and gets a triangle
armbar combination and taps him. Wow.
And this is an Anderson
came into that fight,
injured and her Anderson had a fucked
up rib entering into that fight.
And a lot of people thought
he should have pulled out.
What kind of weird edit is this role?
The blurriness all.
He's strange fan and it was nuts.
It was nuts for that guy.
He'll come and see how he's holding
his side and the moat, the first,
that was the first trash talk
fight ever remember to Oh,
Chels son and people forget how good
he was talking. Shit. He was the best,
the best. He was the best. When I come in,
when Anderson Silva walks into the ring,
you could hear a mouse piston on cotton.
When I walk in,
it's thunder. I mean, the
problems he would cut. Yeah,
we're just the APP that hadn't been
done yet. Now. Not a lot. Well,
Conor Mcgregor Prob,
you know, it's arguable.
The chill was even better than Conor,
but if you take time period into accounts,
no one was doing right.
He was the first and he was building up
fights as a heel for the first time ever.
[inaudible] and brought
them in a little bit later.